die bayerische berglandschaft das ist
ein edel- und damit könnte der kontrast
zu den problemen der welt kaum größer
sein die g7-staaten tagen in einer
besonders schweren zeit im malerischen
ellmau und sie zeigten sich einig
milliarden für die ukraine milliarden
für die bekämpfung des hungers und ein
klima club für einen co2 freien planeten
proteste gab es eher wenig und gastgeber
bundeskanzler scholz wurde vom
amerikanischen präsidenten für sein
engagement gelobt viele gute absichten
bahn folgen jetzt welche taten und
welche botschaft für den moskau gehört
der krisengipfel signal an putin unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
und seine ist auch klar
vor uns liegt eine zeit der unsicherheit
dies herausfordernd und arm sind
entschlossenheit und geschlossenheit
ebenso wichtig
und umso wichtiger ist es dass wir in
dieser welt enge freunde und verbündete
haben die sieben staaten die hier
zusammen gekommen sind sind solche enge
freunde und verbündete bundeskanzler
urlaubsort heute mittag bei der
abschluss-pressekonferenz in ellmau
herzlich willkommen ihnen hier aus
berlin ja was bleibt von diesem
g7-treffen darüber spreche ich mit
diesen gesten ganz herzlich willkommen
kerstin münstermann leiterin des
hauptstadtbüros der rheinischen post
gerade zurück aus elmar wo sie den g 7
gipfel beobachtet dass sie da sind ich
begrüße volker treier er ist
außenwirtschaftschef und mitglied der
hauptgeschäftsführung des deutschen
industrie und handelskammertages und bei
uns ist anna doris carrick sie ist
reporterin und produzentin beim
amerikanischen sender cbs news
oder roland süß ist bei uns er ist
mitglied im bundesweiten
koordinierungskreis von attac und hat
sich die demos gegen die g 7 in münchen
und auch in ellmau mit organisiert
herzlich willkommen frau münstermann sie
kommen gerade zurück wenn man so
umschreiben würde was ist so der
stärkste eindruck der so bleibt nach
diesen tagen in diese noch in dieser
schönen bergkulisse mit diesem besonders
schweren problem drei interessante tage
zwischen kühen und hubschraubern ich
glaube es ist durchaus
kanzler scholz gelungen ein ein bild
eines gipfels zu orchestrieren der wir
dauernd sagte entschlossenheit und
geschlossenheit ausstrahlt ich denke das
ist ihnen gelungen ein bild der
demokratien die gemeinsamen sich gegen
putin stellen ob ein gipfel in dieser
form den wir jetzt hier erlebt haben
noch so angemessen ist mit dem aufwand
mit den kosten mit dem personal das
glaube ich allerdings war aus der zeit
gefallen in zeiten von
klimaprobleme und von energieproblemen
wirkt es doch etwas merkwürdig wenn also
ununterbrochen hubschrauber menschen
zwischen einem schloss und einer einer
berggemeinde hin und her transportieren
das halte ich schon für aus der zeit
gefallen aber für scholz aus meiner
sicht war es mit abstrichen aber doch
eine folge hat im internationalen format
in den tagen gewinnen könnten das ist
mein eindruck herr süß dazu passt ja
auch die kritik die attac hat sie haben
gesagt oder sie finden diese sache auch
nicht mehr zeitgemäß aber trotzdem gibt
es klare auch der verpflichtungen dass
man sich geeinigt hat wie beurteilen sie
denn die ergebnisse also von den ganzen
ergebnissen gibt es dazu sich eine ganze
reihe die jetzt mit der ukraine krieg zu
tun haben
da habe ich so den eindruck es gab
natürlich eine einigkeit innerhalb der
g7-staaten aber deutlich ist doch
geworden das hat eben die gäste da halt
eben nicht mitgenommen worden sind
insofern ist die frage
das ziel in der richtung
irgendwie was zu bewegen ich glaube das
ist jetzt so in dieser form nicht
umgesetzt worden das heißt
da haben wir im prinzip das was zu
erwarten war das halt eben die die
großen industrienationen als eben schon
an einem strang ziehen und sagen klar
wir werden weiter in lambach liefern und
wir werden verschiedene andere dinge tun
ganz ordentlich auch gegen die
hungersnot einzusetzen die hunger ist
nur das ist ein anderes thema da hab mir
eher wird er so ein punkt dass wir sagen
da gibt es von unserer seite kritik
zumindest daran dass in diesen
bestimmungen gerade in dieser erklärung
auch darin steht dass die märkte
die agrarmärkte offen bleiben müssen
ganz einfach und das eine
grundvoraussetzung ist aber dass im
prinzip ein problem ist schon seit
vielen jahren was auch in der welt hans
auch wenn die sonne wti roth diskutiert
wird dass das folgen hat das halt eben
klein bauern in vielen ländern halt eben
afrikas zum beispiel dadurch hat eben
ihre existenz bedroht ist und halt eben
es nicht möglich es halt und
kontinuierlich in solchen ländern halten
agrarprodukte zu so letztendlich halt
eben zu liefern weil halt eben die
großen industrienationen halt eben mit
hoch subventionierten produkten auf dem
markt kommen ganz wichtig dass man sich
um diese hungersnot kümmert das war ein
ganz wichtiger punkt bei g7 von
riskierten wenn sie das jetzt sehen was
da jetzt beschlossen wurde also für alle
viel geld für die ukraine aber auch
gegen hunger dieses co2 klima club ist
das ein punkt wo sie sagen ja dass das
das hat sinn gemacht dass man sich dort
so getroffen hat also sinn hat es auf
jeden fall gemacht weil man in diesen
schweren zeiten mit dem krieg in der
ukraine glaube ich auch ein ganz klares
zeichen setzen musste vor allem auch
nach vier jahren trump wo
transatlantische beziehungen wirklich
sehr gelitten haben erfahren wir jetzt
gerade wieder so eine renaissance und
und vor allem für für kanzler scholz war
das natürlich auch ein wichtiges treffen
weil er sich auch noch mal ganz klar
positionieren konnte was er vielleicht
in den monaten davor nicht ganz so
geschafft hat und für russland und vor
allem auch für china war
finde ich dass das gipfeltreffen auf
jeden fall ein sehr wichtiger ein sehr
wichtiges zeichen dass man eben
geschlossen da ist ja der drei wie
beurteilen sie es wenn man jetzt auch
sieht alle reden von der patronen
wirtschaftskrise wir sie haben die
energiekrise all das wie wichtig war da
dieses treffen und was wäre es ist für
sie das wichtigste ergebnis der iss
treffen war immens wichtig weil wir
leben in zeiten von umbrüchen ich will
das im begriff der zeitenwende nicht
überstrapazieren aber
protektionismus
zeiten der korona krise haben die spuren
hinterlassen
der russische angriffskrieg zeigt das
vermeintliche partnerschaften sich auch
sofort in ihr gegenteil verkehren können
und die unternehmen spüren dass wir
sehen das in der energie-
versorgungskrise wir stehen vor einer
drohenden hungersnot
kroner ist auch nicht vorbei die
versorgung der welt mit medizinischen
produkt mit impfstoffen also all das
zeigt glaube ich dass die globale
arbeitsteilung
weitergehen muss sie geht nicht so
weiter wie bisher aber sie kann auch
nicht auf null gesetzt werden weil sonst
werden die probleme dieser zeit nicht
gelöst ja wenn exportverbote da sind für
weizen und anderes und dagegen stemmen
sich jetzt die g7-länder und setzten
finde ich schon ein bemerkenswertes
zeichen die frage ist ob es einen nur
ein zeichen ist oder ob es wirklich auch
konsequenzen hat und auswirkungen in
richtung putin sie haben sagt das ist
schon ein zeichen gewesen was etwas was
würden sie denn sagen wie das in moskau
aufgenommen wird
sie sagt mir gerade wie wichtig sind
diese gipfelte heutzutage noch ich finde
gerade jetzt wo eigentlich
einmal vor allem europa sich nicht ganz
einig war und zwar gesagt haben man muss
die ukraine unterstützen mit allen
mitteln aber jeder hat ja doch
letztendlich so seine eigenen
probleme und
also ganz klar denke ich dass wand
zeichen dass man sich vielleicht jetzt
doch noch mal zusammen packt und sagt
wir ziehen an einem strang sagen sie
mich falsch verstanden dass die
miteinander reden und das persönlich tun
finde ich total wichtig und zwar genau
in dem format g20 wird sich auch treffen
ich glaube nur die inszenierung also
dass diese gipfel immer im schönsten
panorama im schönsten luxushotel der
länder stattfinden muss halte ich für
nicht mehr konform also es gab ein g 20
treffen in rom da hat man eine nicht
ganz so schöne messe halle gemietet ein
stadtviertel abgeriegelt das ging auch
also ich glaube die inszenierung man
wollte noch mal diese bank habe unter
merkel
sagen dass man das ist halt eben jetzt
weil sie keine idee von von scholz nein
das war also genau aber er hat das
umgesetzt und scholz hat ja wir dürfen
nicht vergessen eine große politische
achillesferse von ihm ist das g 20
treffen in hamburg unter seiner
verantwortung das ging wirklich daneben
das kann man sagen dass da hat nichts
funktioniert und so war das jetzt ein
wirklich unglaublich geschützter gipfel
18.000 polizisten also ich bin immer
diese strecken gefahren und also an
jedem verkehrsschild standen wagen und
man hat wenig protest zugelassen es gab
auch weniger protest gibt sich ja auch
gründe dafür ich finde das sinnvoll und
jetzt auch mal tritt nato es werden ja
auch wenn wir bei diesen gipfeln ganz
schnell entscheidungen getroffen die
länger brauchen und auf einmal werden
sie verkündet also heute konnte die nato
verkünden dass erdogan die türkei also
den widerstand gegen den beitritt von
finnland und schweden aufgegeben hat da
hat man sich getroffen man hat auf
höchster ebene verhandelt das ist glaube
ich total wichtig über die formen lässt
sich wie gesagt streiten aber dann
bleiben noch mal kurz dabei erst mal süß
warum gab es so viel weniger protest es
gab in münchen der demo es gab
demonstranten auch dort aber weniger als
man mit gerechnet hatte ja das ist ja
sag mal die
situation dass man solche bewegungen
solche demonstrationen im vorfeld ja
nicht auf dem reißbrett fünf monate
vorher planen kann und genau weiß was
wird in die letztendlich da in der
zwischenzeit was sind die entscheidenden
themen die diskutiert werden und ich
glaube es war auf alle fällt trotzdem
also da wir selbst sind schon davon
ausgegangen dass man mehr leute
letztendlich auch mobilisieren aber dass
trotzdem ist wichtig war genau das 4000
noch nicht mal in in münchen waren 6000
also das ist unsere sollen die wm-vierte
vier paar tausend die polizei gesagt ja
das
ist klar wir hätten sicherlich auch
mehr gerne mobilisiert aber das ist halt
in die frage was sind dafür die ursache
also einerseits muss man sagen es war
trotzdem richtig wir haben in gewisser
weise deutlich gemacht dass es protest
das ist kritik an gewisser weise der
politik gibt zumindest die schwerpunkte
dieser demonstration waren ja auch
gewesen ein das heißt die klimafrage an
das weiße biodiversitäts frage und als
dritten punkt halt eben die soziale
ungerechtigkeit ist ganz einfach in der
welt gibt und da ist natürlich die
gerade die gesehen ein akteur der
entscheidungen fällt die
eigentlich dann auch die ganze welt
betreffen und das ist ja der die kritik
auch von attac dass wir sagen insofern
was die weltpolitik betrifft kann
eigentlich so ein gremium von 7
industriestaaten nicht für die ganze
welt letztendlich entscheiden ganz reife
und das ist ein punkt wo der haben die
g7 ja auch schon daraus gelernt oder
urlaubs hat ja ganz bewusst auch andere
länder mit gebunden nämlich in dem
südafrika indonesien egal wie wichtig
ist es dass man sich da eröffnet
ich sehe gerade die die
bewältigung globaler probleme da braucht
vorreiter
und wenn wir über die klimakrise
sprechen dann ist deutschland dann ist
der europäische union ist vorreiter
müssen wir aufpassen dass wir
nicht andere verlieren oder umgekehrt
gesagt wir müssen andere mitnehmen und
dann geht es durchaus um gleichgesinnte
partner die sich auf die ziele fest
schreiben aber auch auf die instrumente
also zum beispiel den eingeführten co2
preis in deutschland für sektoren die
noch nicht mal in europa gelten in
europa die noch bei keinem anderen
partnerland gelten kann dazu führen dass
zum beispiel produktion co2 intensivere
produktion wo wir uns auf den weg machen
das zu reduzieren anderswo ausweicht
weil weil es sich hier nicht mehr
rechnet deshalb brauchen wir gemeinsame
spielregeln und deshalb ist zum beispiel
das ergebnis dass jetzt ein klima club
gegründet wird und sich auf gemeinsame
standards festgelegt werden und
hoffentlich dann in dem prozess auf
gemeinsame instrumente also mit gleich
gesehen was bedeutet das dann eigentlich
konkret dann ja zum beispiel dass die
amerikaner im jetzt wieder verbesserten
transatlantischen verhältnis hoffentlich
sich bald auch machen auch ein co2 preis
einzuführen so dass wir zumindest mit
den amerikanern in einem gleich schritt
vorangehen und andere länder mitnehmen
und deshalb finde ich es auch ganz
wichtig das internet dabei war die sind
bei denen dominiert doch stärker
ökonomische kalkül das ist sagen wir
können sie uns noch nicht leisten diese
form der co2 reduktion zu betreiben dort
entstehen ganz viele neue
kohlekraftwerke aber wir müssen im
gespräch sein um die dann auf dem weg zu
überzeugen aber auch mit ökonomischen
argumenten am ende auf unsere seite zu
bringen die geben wie sehr kann das
durchgesetzt werden moszkowicz in den
usa
ich glaube dass es eher
schwierig also jetzt vor allem mit
steigender inflation und einen weiteren
wirtschaftlichen problem vor dem die
auch die usa stehen in verbindung auch
mit dem mit dem konflikt glaube ich also
auch ein beiden hat ja ganz klar gesagt
ich werde jetzt alles versuchen um den
amerikanern den schmerz am gashahn zu
nehmen also der ich mich schwierig gegen
mit einer tankstelle ich stelle mir das
jetzt schwierig vor jetzt mit china
paketen zu kommen und
das war das dann schon mehr als
ich gerade so etwas hat sich als
finanzminister ausgedacht jetzt hat das
umsetzen können aber ich fand es doch
relativ
schwammig formuliert also im laufe des
jahres 2022 dann haben wir die ein klub
der willigen sozusagen also gibt dann
genau das was man der eu immer vermeiden
wollte also zwei geschwindigkeiten ich
bin mir nicht so ganz sicher ob das
wirklich der durchbruch ist andererseits
hat deutschland jetzt in diesen
verhandlungen sehr deutlich gemacht dass
man nach wie vor interesse an fossiler
energie weltweit hat und einer der
partner der da und eingeladen war es
denn egal verfügt über gasvorräte der
hat sehr aufmerksam zugehört als
deutschland jetzt interesse bekundet
dort gas zu fördern also es hat immer
zwei seiten ich glaube das klima hat
gelitten bei diesem gipfel während
sozusagen die einbindung der länder des
globalen südens wie es jetzt immer heißt
tatsächlich auf politisch und auch auf
wirtschaftlicher ebene viel wichtiger
für alle geworden ist auf einmal will
man die im boot haben und will sie gegen
putin vereinen und ist auch bereit das
ist ja nur nicht klar gegen den kreis
gestellt haben ja das geht ja nicht
darum dass man die dazu bringt dass sie
sich gegen putin stellen sondern dass
man versucht das narrativ die sanktionen
des westens bringen eine
nahrungsmittelknappheit über den rest
der welt dass man da sagt nein das ist
putins angriffskrieg dass es die
verursacher der verursacher und das ist
ganz klar nicht das problem was jetzt
die westlichen nationen betrifft oder
was was die über die welt bringen und
ich glaube da ist der versuch schon
sehr stark also wir sehen in südafrikas
präsident zuma hat noch vor ein paar
wochen scholz auf offener bühne
widersprochen und hat gesagt er irrte da
das ist das sei also die westliche sicht
sei nicht die richtige jetzt hat man
versucht das so einzubinden also ich
glaube da ist der versuch steter tropfen
höhlt den stein auch mit blick auf
indien dass man immer wieder versucht
wir binden euch ein und und wir wollen
euch auch sagen wie unsere sicht der
dinge ist und eben nicht nur die
brics-staaten und präsident putin der
der seine sicht der dinge dort sehr
deutlich ist das müsste doch auch in
ihrem interesse sein dass man zwar
findet dieses länder mit ein sie hat das
problem ist aber was passiert hier also
der klima clubs sowie die erklärung
heute veröffentlicht worden ist ist er
relativ
unpräzise also olaf scholz das ist ja
auch sein kind letztendlich was da in
die welt gesetzt hat hat er da schon
deutlicher auch in der vergangenheit
gesagt was er darunter versteht zum
beispiel auch auf dem world economic
forum sechsundzwanzigster mai in davos
dort hat er gesagt wir haben uns
vorgenommen die g7 zum kern eines
internationalen klima clubs zu machen da
die pariser klimaziele beschleunigt
umsetzen dieser klubs stelle steht allen
staaten offen wenn sie sich auf
bestimmte mindeststandards verpflichten
so schaffen wir ein level playing field
und verhindern dass unterschiedliche
regeln den wettbewerb verzerren da wird
schon dann mehr deutlich und zwar in der
richtung dass es jetzt eigentlich um
fragen der wirtschaft des handels bei
dieser frage geht das die akteure das
heißt es ist in dem fall zunächst
hauptsächlich halt die g7-staaten dass
die tisch standard setzen wollen und die
anderen länder die dann dazu kommen die
sind dann werden dann nur aufgenommen
wenn sie sich an diese standards halten
dh wenn es
da wir hätten wieder einmal regeln
festgelegt von von einer gruppe von
feuer von industrien endlich ja nicht
verbindlich sind ja das ist schon immer
die frage wie werden standards
geschaffen dass wenn also
das führte dazu dass das ist ja auch das
interesse das halt eben dann es
verschiedene kooperationen gibt die
miteinander
geknüpft sind und es wird auf alle fälle
dazu dass der standards geschaffen
werden die man entweder eingehalten
werden müssen von den ländern oder halt
eben dass ich dann nicht rein kennen
können und ich sage mal solche solche
regelungen während eigentlich sinnvoller
aufgehoben wenn sie halt eben in
internationalen gremien letztendlich
entstehen soll und ihr sie findet also
dieses gremium an sich nicht gut dass
das die das verbinden das ist letztlich
habe ich klar geworden jetzt ich würde
trotzdem noch mal fragen herr dreyer wie
wichtig ist es dass deutschland da ja
sozusagen da voran geht und wie hat
scholz diese rolle jetzt auch genommen
das wurde mir vorher gesagt dass er da
zu zaudern ist zu zögerlich und
deutschland müsste jetzt mal klare ja so
eine führungsrolle auch haben hat er das
jetzt geschafft
vor dem hintergrund der vielfältigen
probleme und einer zeit in der es auch
multilaterale
oder zumindest internationale
zusammenarbeit insgesamt schwierig ist
sieht man ja auch bei der frage der der
verurteilung des russischen
angriffskriegs in der ukraine in der un
vollversammlung
also vor diesem hintergrund glaube ich
sind die ergebnisse wirklich beachtlich
müssen differenzieren zwischen
kurzfristigen ganz ganz drängenden
problemen und mindest mittelfristigen
probleme kurzfristig haben wir droht
eine weltrezession es droht eine
hungerkrise
und wir haben eine energie versorgungs
krise in weiten teilen des globus wenn
wir von standards reden wie für das
mittelfristige ziel nämlich die
bekämpfung des klimawandels
dann muss ich sagen finde ich es besser
wenn die g7 wer ist dem fehlt überhaupt
standard zu setzen dass die g7 standard
setzen oder sich verpflichten standards
zu setzen das ist vage aber gemessen an
dem wie wo die amerikaner zum beispiel
stehen beim thema inflation prägende
thema dort
gaspreise und midterms wahlen
finde ich dann die formierung eines
thema clubs das video standard setzen
und vielleicht wie etwa china durchaus
besser und beachtlich sondern wie sehr
hat der oder falls diese rolle jetzt
angenommen dass und er wurde er gelobt
vom amerikanischen präsidenten ganz zu
anfang also wie wir das gerne szene da
stand er das war ja sein erster gast und
es ist ja auch der der wichtigste gast
wenn man so will und dann stand er kurz
alleine und das protokoll lief nicht so
wie geplant und er musste im moment
länger warten und lief dann da doch so
ein bisschen nervös auf und ab also ich
glaube das war schon eine große
feuerprobe dir da so zur feuertaufe zu
bestehen hatte so sagt man und dann kam
der präsident und hat ihm also wirklich
einen großen gefallen getan er hat ihnen
marc offenbar ist könnten sie sich ja
besser beurteilen aber die körperliche
nähe also er hat ihn sofort irgendwie
die schulter geklopft der amerikaner dem
olaf scholz und hat gesagt so toll
gemacht und vielen dank und so weiter
das mag banal sein aber es war für
scholz der sich ja vor allem national
aber auch international viel kritik
anhören müssen glaube ich einfach einen
durchbruch ein erfolg aber der
eigentliche erfolg und deswegen war
glaube ich joe biden auch so aufgelegt
war ja dann doch die woche davor dass
schon wieder ein bisschen vergessen aber
als feuz zusammen mit magna und dem
italienischen präsidenten draghi und dem
rumänen dem rumänischen präsidenten in
kiew war und dort einfach gezeigt hat
vollkommene unterstützung wir liefern
die schweren waffen die die ukraine will
vielleicht langsamer als die sie will
aber wir tun was und ich glaube da hat
er sich dann eine gute woche später die
internationale anerkennung abgeholt
also ich würde auch sagen mit dem lob
war dass so ein switch beim
bundeskanzler dass er wirklich so ein
charakter bekommen hat vor allem nach
der ganzen kritik und die letzten
letzten zehn tage waren hier wirklich
totale sagt man veränderungen auch weil
man wie gesagt jetzt den tatendrang bzw
wie sagt man die der die taten sieht die
nach den ganzen worten von un und eu
gipfel und jetzt genau so wollte aber
der nato und das ist auf jeden fall auch
ein gutes timing und und mit dem look
von von joe biden hat er glaube ich also
wie wird urlaubsort wie wird deutschland
in bälde wird deutschland überhaupt
wahrgenommen interessiert das überhaupt
jemanden natürlich also auf jeden fall
einmal als ein land was auf jeden fall
auch eine verantwortung hat und sich
daran beteiligen muss eben waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern mit der sie sich
verteidigen können und es wurde
natürlich wahrgenommen das ist alles
langsam passiert ist und nicht so
schnell wie von von den
anderen partnern aber letztendlich hat
sich ja auch die waage der bundeskanzler
auch immer ist sicher dann doch
letztendlich klar positioniert und
gesagt wir liefern die waffen es dauert
halt einfach ist alles hat braucht seine
zeit und dafür wurde er letztendlich
gelobt ist er denn
den taten vielleicht dürftig noch auf
zwei errungenschaften ist nicht nur
dieses gipfels aber der g7 hinweisen
also erstens dass
der angriffskrieg russlands in der
ukraine
unisono verurteilt wurde und mit
gemeinsamen von allen ländern getragenen
sanktionen beantwortet worden sind ich
meine natürlich trägt letztlich die
wirtschaft und dann auch die menschen
auch in deutschland und europa folgen
diese dieser dieser sanktionen aber wir
haben wir große unterstützung auch in
der deutschen wirtschaft die gesagt
haben diese sanktionen sind jetzt
notwendig aber ganz wichtig sie sind
nicht isoliert und abweichend zum
beispiel zwischen der europäischen union
und den vereinigten staaten getätigt
worden so dass es am ende zu
auslegungsprobleme kommt und zu klagen
auch da hatte nämlich unsere importe
konnte man sich nicht einigen
eine preisobergrenze
hat man sich jetzt noch nicht geeinigt
ich glaube da kann man auch
unterschiedlicher meinung sein aber ich
will noch ein anderes thema nennen die
in aussicht stellen für auch die
südliche hemisphäre
eines eines großen
infrastrukturprogramms über 600
milliarden dollar
was man auch als antwort auf die neue
seidenstraße initiative die chinesen
sehen kann dass auch ihre aus privaten
investition gespeist werde ich meine
jetzt muss geliefert werden das ist klar
der gipfel
kann erstmal absicht und er hat an der
stelle absichtsbekundung geliefert aber
jetzt muss natürlich dann auch
tatsächlich diesen versprochenen summen
auch taten und konkrete projekte folgen
lassen müssen er ich wollte noch kurz
ergänzen weil die frage war hat putin
denn darauf reagiert ich fand das sehr
sehr interessant dass also am tag zwei
das gibt es glaube ich aus moskau kam
dass vladimir putin auf jeden fall
gedenkt zum g20 gipfel im november nach
indonesien zu reisen dort persönlich
teilzunehmen kurz vorher war ja die
debatte
sanktionieren wir das fahren wir da
überhaupt hin als g7 setzen wir uns dort
eventuell mit putin an einem tisch oder
nicht ich fand interessant dass man sich
da nicht verständigt hat das also quasi
offen lässt weil es wäre sicher falsch
jetzt völlig gesprächskanäle
auszuschließen aber heute abend hat doch
schon gesagt dass man schon davon
ausgeht dass man will das ja und will
diesen g20-gipfel g20 club ja nicht
sprengen deshalb geht man schon aus dass
man dahingegen aber genau also man hat
sich geeinigt sich noch nicht offiziell
auf irgendwas zu einigen aber mein pferd
er hin und das gab vor ein paar wochen
war er auf keinen fall was ich damit
sagen will es ist macht was es macht
auch was international mit mit diesen
bildern und das wird auch was mit
wladimir putin machen dessen land immer
stärker wirtschaftlich unter druck gerät
kam auch in diesen tagen was wir aber
auch sehen ist am tag des gipfels gab es
verstärkt wieder raketenalarm ntfs gab
den schrecklichen angriff auf ein
einkaufszentrum
also der krieg ist nicht vorbei oder ich
beende ich ganz gern mal zu also wie
wichtig ist das also von von ihrer seite
aus aus aus der opposition von vielen
ngo s und attac ist eine davon man sagt
man will eben diesem jahr diesen krieg
etwas entgegensetzen und dann ist es
schon richtig gibt es auf dem punkt wo
sie sagen es ist richtig so wie ich sich
g7 da verhalten und das macht dann auch
sinn dass die zusammen da ebenso klar
gegen putin stehen
natürlich ist es vollkommen klar dass
das diese klarheit oder gegen diese
aggression natürlich
vollkommen richtig ist die frage ist nur
braucht man dafür so ein
g7-treffen irgendwo das ist mir jetzt
werden wir jetzt nicht klar dass die
unterschiede vor hat er irgendwie viel
größer gewesen wären irgendwie und es
gibt sehr viele kanäle dies ist daher
immer wieder gegeneinander abstimmen
also ich sage mal natürlich hat jetzt
dieses thema ukraine krieg jetzt eine
große bedeutung ist aktueller bei diesen
treffen habt aber insgesamt wäre doch
eingesehen treffen vegas vega dieser
frage nicht zustanden gekommen das hat
doch eigentlich eine ganz andere aufgabe
und zwar hat mir eine aufgabe von
wirtschaftlicher kooperation und
abstimmung und 720 wenn sie das denn
dann sinnvoll na gut sagt die g7
vertreten zehn prozent der
weltbevölkerung die g-20 vertretung für
40 prozent der weltbevölkerung
da fehlt dann eben 80 80 prozent der
weltbevölkerung genau 40 prozent ist sie
würden dann immer noch 20 prozent fehlen
ganz einfach und die frage ist g 20
jahre hat 83 fehlen immer noch 20
insofern viele dinge die da diskutiert
werden sollten eigentlich im rahmen der
uno und solcher institutionen ganz
einfach wir
ja aber wenn man sich dann nicht wenn
die auf den weg macht da was zu ändern
weil man nicht zum beispiel nicht her
geht und sagt wir müssen endlich mal die
uno so reformieren dass er arbeitsfähig
ist und wir müssen auch gucken dass die
unter so ausgestreckt finanziell
ausgestaltet wird weil das ist ja das
geht durch fast alle staaten das duo
finanziell i7 und g20 vertreten zu wenig
teile der welt würden sie sich dagegen
gespannt ich würde sagen der g20 gipfel
gibt und da habe ich der ganzen
internationalen community noch mal die
chance vielleicht nochmal raum für
diplomatie offen zu lassen wir wissen
noch nicht wie sich jetzt der sommer
hinsichtlich der des krieges entwickelt
erst mitte november of glory und wenn es
sich weiterhin zuspitzt vor allem auch
was was atomwaffen angeht dann erinnern
wir uns an die kuba krise dann sollten
vielleicht doch noch raum lassen für
diplomatie und dann es geht zum gipfel
wie wird der g 20 auf jeden fall eine
möglichkeit das wäre eine möglichkeit um
halt eben ein deutliches zeichen nach
moskau auch zusenden per dreier was
halten sie jetzt für die für das
wichtigste signal gerade gegenüber putin
haben sie den eindruck dass das
irgendetwas bewegen kann
ja sie die geschlossenheit ist ist
wichtig und es ist auch wichtig dass ihr
fünf weitere länder mit dabei waren ja
neben der ukraine auch vertreter länder
das des globalen südens ja mit
argentinien auch noch ein land der g 20
die bislang nicht alle gesagt haben
wir sind eindeutig auf der auf der auf
eurer seite diesen diesen angriffskrieg
als solchen zu brandmarken
beziehungsweise auf sanktionen gegenüber
russland zu machen also vielleicht auch
gefährdet zu sein
russland bemüht sich an anderer stelle
so einen eigenen klub aufzubauen also
diese bezeichnung der der der bric oder
briggs
ist ja weiterhin existent und zum
treffen gab es ja auch letzte woche
glaube ich und und deshalb ist es auch
wichtig und vielleicht ganz besonders
wichtig dass mit dem senegal gesprochen
wurde mit südafrika mit indien mit
indonesien ja dass trotz der differenz
der auch ganz geht auch um eine neue
weltordnung dass man auch mal auf das
jahr 2050 schaut also ist das sind da
muss man nur dran bleiben also ich
glaube jetzt
lippenbekenntnisse angesichts der krise
und das wieder zu vergessen ich finde
die südafrikanische außenministerin hat
gestern im deutschen fernsehen ein
interessantes interview gegeben und die
hat also ein bisschen übersetzt so
gesagt also ganz ehrlich gebt uns nie
gefragt in den letzten jahren und jetzt
auf einmal wollen wir springen nicht
verkürzt so dass mal und ich fand das
hat sie
zu recht so vorgetragen und ich glaube
schon dass dieser dialog den man will
das ist bei dem bleiben muss und das ist
vielleicht die überlegungen gibt zu g7
künftig immer diese partner oder andere
partner dazu bitten also dass es eben
mehr ist als nur dieser exklusive club
was sie vorhin gesagt haben und die idee
wir brauchen uns am ende alle gemeinsam
um sein abwehr eines die welt vernichten
atomkriegs was die krücken gesagt haben
ist das ja auch schon also eine
erkenntnis die hätte man früher haben
können aber jetzt ist sie da und dann
ist es sinnvoll ist aber doch die
innenpolitik die dann wieder ganz viel
bestimmen wenn wir dann in die usa
schauen wenn sie sagen letztendlich wird
es geht es darum wie an wird an der
tankstelle entschieden und nicht denkt
der denkt keiner an eine globale
strategie für 2015 zu
dem interview ist sie hatte auch zum
beispiel gesagt dass es auch andere
krisen gibt und dass alle krisen also in
dem interview die außenministerin von
südafrika dass sie der meinung ist dass
alle krisen letztendlich gleich
behandelt werden müssten und das ist
natürlich kriegerische
auseinandersetzung und unterdrückung in
vielen teilen der welt gibt und insofern
haben sie hat sie gesagt wenn dann muss
man auch daher die gleichen maßstäbe
anlegen
ich wollte noch mal zu den usa sagen
dass es sich natürlich jetzt ist es ein
akutes thema für uns alle aber da eben
die haushalte ist mittlerweile merken
dass der
der eu keine krise der ukraine krieg der
die die wirtschaft belastet denke ich
auch zu den mit heinz henn wird sich der
fokus auf jeden fall ein bisschen
abwenden von von der krise keine also
man schaut noch mehr nach innen als nach
außen vertreibers los was muss man da
befürchten wenn man sieht wie dieser
krieg weitergeht wir wissen aber nicht
wie lange er gehen wird wenn wir jetzt
den g20 gipfel ist eben november
vielleicht ist das eine chance für eine
diplomatie mit putin aber was erwarten
sie da und wie sehr kann man dann ja
kann man dann diese diese ideen die
jetzt auf dem g7-gipfel
geboren sind kann man die dann umsetzen
oder schaut dann doch jedes land eben
dann doch auf seine eigene
wirtschaftskrise also wenn jedes land
auch seine eigene krise schaut
und das miteinander irgendwo in
vergessenheit gerät und jetzt ist
miteinander bei all den differenzen
besser die g 7 haben ein miteinander und
haben das jetzt mal artikuliert und sich
dann auf dem g20 gipfel vorzubereiten
allemal besser als gäbe es das nicht und
die gespräche mit den ländern wie
senegal in den ich muss ich mir alles
nicht aufzählen sind absolut wichtig um
diesen gemeinsamen themen die jetzt
anstehen zu adressieren also wenn jetzt
jedes land exportverbote macht bei
getreide
dann wird es die hungerkrise geben weil
einfach nicht genügend da ist und und
vielleicht gerade die stärkeren länder
sich in die pflicht nehmen wenn die
anderen auch auf solche form von
welthandelsorganisation niedrigen
instrumenten verzichten trotzdem
unterstützt werden dass wir diese
hungersnot abwenden können oder
zumindest eine ernährungskrise lindern
können das ist nur ein beispiel
und also die situation ist
weltwirtschaftlich wirklich prekär und
deshalb glaube ich sind die
kurzfristigen herausforderungen jetzt zu
adressieren ja wir haben nicht
gesprochen über über notenbank
zinssteigerungen als folge von von
inflation in den usa zum beispiel was
einen enormen kapitalabzug von einigen
entwicklungs oder schwellenländer im
moment zur folge hat deren währungen
purzeln runter und die die die schlitten
in
prekäre staatsschuldenkrisen rein und
das wird dann die probleme dieser länder
vergrößern und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass nicht nur jedes land auf sich
gemeinsam schaut sondern wir diese
themen möglichst gemeinsam jetzt g7
hoffentlich dann bei g 20 in einem
nächsten schritt auch nochmal
adressieren weil die 20 bin natürlich
skeptisch rüssel und ist dabei zu sein
dass dabei ist die frage wie russland
steht und die frage ist wo china steht
räumen sondern was ist ihr eindruck dass
welche rolle war schien ja sozusagen der
elefant im raum der dann über den dann
doch zu wenig gesprochen wurde oder wo
man auf der einen seite sieht man doch
sehr freundlich in china gegenüber und
auch den konflikt mit taiwan jetzt nicht
so so ganz doll erwähnt auf der anderen
seite ist schon klar dass putin vor
allem versucht mit china eine eine achse
zu bilden eine allianz zu bilden und
dass ihm das in teilen auch gelingt und
deswegen die amerikaner sind da sehr
viel
vorsichtiger gegenüber china haben sehr
viel mehr den wollten sehr viel mehr
druck haben die europäer mit blick auf
die wirtschaft sind da etwas
zurückhaltender gewesen also ich glaube
da war man sich noch nicht so ganz einig
wie die wie die künftige strategie
gegenüber china denn aussehen soll aber
klar ist ja also das was man bei
russland lange verdrängt hat anti
demokratische bewegungen und
unterdrückung und keine grundrechte
gewähren das ist wahr in russland so
dass es in china noch viel mehr so und
abhängigkeiten von seltenen erden et
cetera das sind die probleme die werden
gar nicht thematisiert also so ein
bisschen haben wir glaube ich den china
moment vielleicht dann in ein paar
jahren
genau also ordentlich ist auch so ein
bisschen ein wenn man die den auftritt
von joe biden so ein bisschen beobachtet
hatte ich das gefühl das ist erst da und
gibt quasi dem bundeskanzler ein
bisschen selbstbewusstsein und du hast
das alles gut gemacht und ist auf dem
richtigen weg und europa muss
zusammenhalten und eine eine linie
fahren mit vor allem
sicherheitspolitischen fragen in erster
linie weil unser fokus wird in den
nächsten jahren auf jeden fall ein
anderer sein also der der amerikaner und
zwar was im südchinesischen meer
eigentlich passiert und deswegen glaube
ich dass die usa als
sicherheitsgarant vor allem als ewiger
sicherheitsgarant der europäer langsam
gibt es wird immer verstanden weil man
weiß ja auch nicht jetzt ist das
transatlantische verhältnis ja wieder
gut aber wenn donald schauen zum
beispiel wieder präsident werden würde
wäre das ja ganz anders und dass das ist
man dass man darüber ist man sich auch
bewusst dass dann natürlich geht die
politik bzw
die beziehungen zu putin natürlich ganz
anders aus während war auch dass die
amerikanische delegation also es gab
eine große aufregung präsident seelands
geld gesprochen erst hieß es diese
presse diese rede sei auch
presseöffentlich dann hieß es sie sei
jedoch vertraulich und mein mann würde
nichts preisgeben währenddessen haben
die amerikaner aber ihre journalisten
und delegationen gebrieft über diese
rede und das wurde dann schöne
veröffentlicht ins internet gestellt da
sagen die deutschen berater des herrn
scholz dann etwas waren etwas riskiert
denn klar als journalist wunderschön
dann nehme ich halt die information der
amerikaner hauptsache ich komme
überhaupt irgendwie an das was präsident
der letzte jahr nicht unter modell ist
ja dauernd in der öffentlichkeit also
kann man auch diese rede die ihr dort
von sich gibt sozusagen an ich finde da
kann man dann auch teilhaben das bewegt
die weltöffentlichkeit und also die
amerikaner haben die deutschen ja schon
so ein bisschen getrieben also die haben
eine andere informationspolitik verfolgt
und da hinten also die die deutschen
etwas hinterher das zeigt auch so ein
bisschen also ich glaube der das
selbstverständnis des amerikanischen
präsidenten ist noch ein ganz anderes
das dürfte so dass das dann noch ein
anderes ist eine amerikanische präsident
da ist es war ja auch der erste gipfel
von von olaf scholz in dieser funktion
das ja nochmal was anderes wenn was
würden sie sich denn wünschen was würden
sie sagen wann gibt es einen punkt wo
sie nicht mehr demonstrieren würden
also ich glaub rechnung machen
also ich finde wir hatten ja eine
entwicklung nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
wo es sehr deutlich geworden ist dass es
solche internationalen investoren und
solche entwicklungen geben muss und wir
haben mittlerweile eine entwicklung dass
es sich immer mehr blöcke bilden und ich
glaube über solche regelungen wie es die
g7 versucht irgendwo noch ein paar
länder um sich so zu kopieren so wird
sich der konflikt längerfristig nicht
lösen können lassen irgendwie insofern
glaube ich wir brauchen wieder
internationale zusammenarbeit die halt
eben über diese stativen versucht halt
eben die gruppen um sich zur gewählten
hinausgehen weil mir anschauen china
indien russland und so weiter wenn die
ein ventil irgendwann der gegend blog
letztendlich geben würden irgendwie dann
sag ich mal sagen haben wir wirklich
zwei
pole die die letztendlich halt eben
nicht dazu insofern ist die frage haben
wir noch eine möglichkeit auf
internationaler ebene die verschiedenen
interessen der verschiedenen
dann noch ins gespräch zu kriegen
mitzubringen schwierig solange russland
sich so verhält als erster
unabhängig von ihrem krieg natürlich
dass das muss man da die in diesem punkt
sicherlich ausklang
die sind jetzt alle weitergereist direkt
zum nächsten gipfel nämlich zum
nato-gipfel wir haben es ja eben schon
gehört dass türkei ihren widerstand
aufgibt zu schweden und finnland wie
wichtig ist das oder wie ist die nato
letztendlich dann doch noch das
wichtigere gremium auch für die eureka
ja mit sicherheit also tatsächlich weiß
wenn er in der amerikanischen
öffentlichkeit eigentlich niemand so
wirklich was der g7 gipfel eigentlich
bedeutet nato eigentlich auch nicht so
viele aber auf jeden fall vor allem
jetzt mit mit finnland und schweden und
der nato erweiterung ist es schon ein
thema weil man natürlich auch ein stück
weit sich wie gerade erwähnt habe so ein
bisschen zurückzieht als amerika der ja
der gesagt mein haupt
[Musik]
sicherheitsgarant okay sind wir gespannt
am donnerstag eine dieser nato-gipfel
dann sprechen wir in der phoenix runde
auch darüber ihn erstmal vielen dank für
die diskussion über den g 7 gipfel ist
eine spannende woche bei uns geht es
jetzt weiter mit phoenix der tagen
morgen reden wir über die drohende
wirtschaftskrise schauen auf
personalmangel und preisschock seien sie
doch wieder dabei bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]